somewhere tonight in the Verizon Center
in Washington DC magic will happen maybe
not here but maybe Heath or here or here
and definitely here the kiss cams magic
doesn't happen by chains they have to
select the kissers keep a few secrets at
work in arena crowd not just a couple
the kiss-cam is the story of a high tech
theatrical production and a business
model falling in love a few decks above
the court is a guy locked to come to a
headset Zak Grimm's the manager of game
entertainment anything that happens in
the arena Bowl on a game night that is
not the game of basketball kind of my
domain that means he's cutting through
the activity of the game night to find
the right couples PR the ones that kind
of execute it so we create all the
graphics that go around it
we're on headset trying to pick out
where all the couples are in the crowd
saying oh the section 220 looks like
it's got a lot of good people in it put
a camera on that let's find a couple
there so we're the ones actually
executing it and Zach's always connected
to somebody in the windowless control
room on the ground floor somebody who's
put a president and the first lady on
the kiss can I was the one who did that
yes Quentin Q for short has a feed of
every camera constantly ready and he's
locked into cameraman who can give him
options he cuts between them as Zach
fills up each discrete programming
segment from The Wizard girls to the
money machine to the kiss cam making the
whole night of production with a ton of
moving parts all that effort only makes
sense because the kiss cam isn't an
accident it's a business model made for
modern sports the history the kiss cam
is recent
but hazing some people credit the
Dodgers others think the Marlins came up
with it at some point in the early 90s
and it makes sense because nobody knew
kiss cams would become a phenomenon but
in some ways they were a foregone
conclusion arenas have big incentives to
maximize revenue in the facility that
money is often kept in a different pot
from the NBA and sometimes the arena and
team are separate entities
so that's why you see a bevy of
sponsored fan packages sponsored blimps
LED wrap arounds courtesy of large banks
and though basketball fans are
passionate about the folk dances of the
Republic of Turkey you're probably only
seen it thanks to a cheque from Eddie
hot Airlines and that's why the kiss-cam
is sponsored two video boards Jumbotrons
the branded term are a big and shiny
example of arenas profit centers they
are powerful sales tools in serving ads
fans basically and they're also part of
sponsorship fields because of the
location fans are a captive audience and
they are amazingly effective at giving
the attention to people in the arena and
that's one reason they put so much work
into making the kiss can click if a
couple doesn't kiss that's not a bad
thing so it'll come back whatever makes
for a good show is a good kiss back
cannot believe it oh my there you go
the kiss cam is part of a sponsored
package with two audiences the fans and
the people who pay for it the occasional
plant happens to
all right women but usually the love is
legitimate what happens in Verizon
Center is not a game it's different
every time because new people want their
shot at video board glory
lay down
oh all right
one more after that
there's no referee here just applause
okay let them kiss you'll stay with
honey honey
at all
it's a professional show put on by
people at the top of their field to make
fans happy and bring in a lot of cash oh
there's a basketball game too all we had
to do was be prepared for her to be
pulled out of the camera and there'd be
a lot of silly string she like thought
he was furry and cute so like I hope he
doesn't steal my girl
two minutes that's what